est-ce que Madame Bartoli va avoir un
chevalet d'accord merci beaucoup
je vous propose que que nous commençons
remercier les collègues ici présents
madame la rapporteur
mesdames un grand merci pour votre pour
votre présence
donc on commence aujourd'hui les travaux
en fait de notre commission d'enquête
qui a été installée la semaine dernière
sur donc sur la pénurie de médicaments
et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française puisque
tout est lié de la Procure de production
à la dispensation
pour cette première audition nous
recevons donc Madame un professeur
Dominique Le gülüdeck qui est président
de la Haute Autorité de Santé
et Madame Fabienne Bartoli directrice
générale de la HS vous m'autoriserez à
dire HS
mes propos
d'ailleurs quand on dit HS les gens se
repèrent plus vite que avec autorité de
santé souvent
et donc merci beaucoup de vous être
mobilisés dans un délai aussi bref donc
si la HAS n'est pas directement
responsable du suivi de la gestion des
pénuries elle est toutefois chargée
d'évaluer le service attendu des
médicaments et des mettre des avis sur
leurs conditions de description ou
d'utilisation rôle éminemment important
et majeurs au-delà la HS contribue à
l'évaluation de la qualité de la prise
en charge sanitaire de la population par
le système de santé c'est pourquoi il
nous semblait intéressant de vous
auditionner le plus tôt possible le plus
précocement possible dans le cas de
cette commission d'enquête afin
d'entendre d'emblée une analyse des
conséquences des pénuries sur la prise
en charge des patients puisque on ne
traite pas que une question quantitative
auprès de bien évidemment une question
de santé publique la HS est mis aussi
des recommandations de bonnes pratiques
à destination des professionnels de
santé et certifient les hôpitaux sans
doute pourrez-vous nous éclairer
également sur la manière dont les
difficultés d'approvisionnement
affectent les stratégies thérapeutiques
ce qui intuitivement Paris assez logique
et plus largement le travail des
professionnels de santé nous vous
interrogerons sur la meilleure manière
de les accompagner
et nous souhaiterions madame la
présidente Madame la Directrice générale
que vous puissiez formuler dans une
brève présentation introductive aux
principaux constats sur la situation
actuelle et sur le rôle de la Haute
Autorité de Santé
sur le rôle qu'elle peut être amenée à
jouer dans la prévention des pénuries où
les réponses à y apporter en sachant que
cette question des pénuries n'est pas
une question tout à fait récente même si
elle a connu une accusation particulière
pendant la période hivernale des de la
triple épidémie je passerai ensuite la
parole donc à Laurence corrèm notre
rapporteur heureux de notre commission
d'enquête et je précise que cette
audition est diffusée en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat elle fera
l'objet bien évidemment d'un
compte-rendu publié avant de vous passer
la parole madame la présidente Madame la
Directrice générale je vous rappelle
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission d'enquête et passible des
peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal et je
vous invite toutes les deux à prêter
serment et de dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité en levant la main droite
et en disant je le jure
je vous remercie
madame la Présidente et Madame la
Directrice vous avez la parole pour une
intervention libinaire et ensuite nous
passerons la parole donc à notre
rapporteur de façon à ce qu'elle puisse
lancer les échanges
merci beaucoup
merci de votre invitation
j'avais déjà été auditionné avec le
professeur norberyfra en 2018 sur le
même sujet à commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat puisque en effet que
comme vous le dites il ne s'agit pas
d'un problème récent mais il s'agit d'un
problème qui s'aggrave il est clair que
les pénuries de médicaments que nous
vivons sont de plus en plus récurrentes
et vous avez vu que c'est une
préoccupation majeure dès lors que ce
sont des maladies graves qui sont
concernées ou à fortiorer nos enfants
il est évident qu'elles entraînent des
conséquences en matière de santé santé
pour les patients directement mais
également santé publique par exemple
quand il s'agit de vaccins
mais également probablement un
gaspillage de temps médical donc vous
savez pourtant qu'en ce moment il est
particulièrement précieux vu les
difficultés RH que rencontre notamment
nos hôpitaux
alors
je tiens à dire quand même de façon
préliminaire que nous n'avons pas bien
que ce sujet
nous sommes soyons particulièrement
sensibles à ce sujet puisqu'il impacte
directement la qualité des soins
nous ne disposons pas la HS à rebours de
la NSM comme vous l'avez dit de
compétences dans la gestion des pénuries
qu'elle soit de vaccins ou de
médicaments donc nous n'avons pas
réellement de vision
quantitative ou qualitative fine sur ces
phénomènes pour l'achat c'est un est
amené à intervenir dans des situations
particulières dont je vous donnerai
quelques exemples
un peu plus tard on pourra revoir par
contre
la HS est en charge de la politique
vaccinale et donc nous sommes
régulièrement amenés à ajuster modifier
la stratégie vaccinale pour répondre à
des situations potentielles de pénurie
alors quand il y a une pénurie de vaccin
on est fait nous proposons soit des
modifications de la stratégie soit des
priorisations soi-même des ajustements
de schéma vaccinal
et puis on l'a vu pendant la crise covid
on peut pas dire que c'était une pénurie
mais c'était une arrivée de dose
progressive donc une pénurie relative
par rapport aux besoins je dirais et
bien des priorisations de population à
vacciner
dans des cas particuliers alors on peut
citer aussi la vaccination contre les
infections à pneumocoque
qu'il y avait qui s'était produite et
qui nous avait amené à c'était en 2018
il y avait eu des fortes tensions
d'approvisionnement en vaccin pneumoax
et nous avions été saisis donc par le
directeur général de la Santé pour
prioriser les populations qui devaient
bénéficier de cette vaccination et puis
déterminer le schéma vaccinal
transitoire qui permettait de garantir
l'accès à cette vaccination pour ces
populations c'est un exemple
alors cette période là la chaise avait
déjà déploré les épisodes répétés de
rupture d'aproseificiellement de vaccin
en particulier et les difficultés que ça
peut engendrer sur la mise en oeuvre de
la stratégie vaccinale et la couverture
vaccinale et nous avions insisté pour
que les dispositions soient prises pour
limiter ces ruptures et
travailler sur la transparence quand
elle leur cause
donc on avait dans cette recommandation
déterminer les populations prioritaires
et de même à nouveau sur le pneumocoque
pendant la crise covid au début de la
crise nous avons reprisé les personnes
qui susceptibles de bénéficier de cette
vaccination pneumovacs puisque là encore
en mars 21 et vu le compte en jumpement
de cette spécialité
il fallait gérer au mieux les doses que
nous avions et donc nous avions rappelé
les populations prioritaires dans une
cas où la situation de pénurie se
maintiendrait au-delà des mesures de
confinement
encore une fois un autre exemple de
tenir une relative et on reparlera des
différentes causes de pénurie c'est la
stratégie vaccinale que vous avez pu
voir se mettre en place pendant le covid
et en effet les populations prioritaires
que nous avions déterminées dépendait au
fil de l'eau des doses que la France
recevait et donc évidemment on
élargissant la population prioritaire en
fonction des doses
voilà alors parfois sur ces in nous
pouvons également répondre aux
alternatives lorsqu'un produit est en
pénurie
par exemple
mais c'est de façon marginale par
rapport à la NSM en 2016 il y avait une
pénurie de techniciens 99 qui est un
produit radioactif qui permet de faire
des examens qui sont essentiels et la
NSM avec les sociétés savantes avaient
priorisé gérer cette pénurie de
technicienne nous avions été par exemple
interroger sur une situation très
particulière qui est celle de la femme
enceinte quand il y a une suspicion
d'embolie pulmonaire puisque le scanner
est il y a des alternatives à cet examen
mais qui peuvent être plus irradiantes
et donc il était nécessaire de bien
déterminer la procédure les bonnes
procédures la bonne prise en charge
d'une femme avec une suspicion d'embolie
pulmonaire d'une femme enceinte voilà
donc avec des situations assez
particulières sur lequel nous sommes
interrogés pour faire face aux
alternatives possibles et aux bonnes
conduites à tenir en situation de
pénurie
dans ce que fait la chas en dehors de
ces interventions qui sont comme vous le
voyez assez ponctuel dans le covid je
citerai aussi nous sommes intervenus
vous savez que pendant le covid la SAS a
pris l'initiative de pour aider les
professionnels qui étaient extrêmement
gênée dans leur pratique et très perdus
dans leur pratique soit lié au
confinement soit la pathologie elle-même
nous avions fait de ce qu'on appelle des
réponses rapides c'est-à-dire ce sont
des recommandations très rapides qui
n'ont pas toute la base scientifique
qui est une recommandation de la HS
habituelle mais qui est faite avec des
professionnels avec des patients
toujours avec les mêmes méthodes de
rigueur et puis de
d'absents de liens d'intérêt de contrôle
déontologique mais de façon très très
rapide c'est à dire qu'on a un groupe de
travail qu'on a mobilisé en permanence
et nous avions été
sollicités pour la prise en charge médic
des situations d'anxiolyse et de
sédation à un moment
où le midazole midasola était
très
en pénurie c'était une augmentation des
besoins en tension là il s'agissait
d'une augmentation de besoin massives et
donc d'un usage parcimonieux et des
alternatives possibles à l'usage du
midazolam dans nos réanimations ou dans
les
ou dans les soins palliatifs
donc nous avions effectué ce type de
travail pour aider les professionnels à
mieux gérer ses patients
un dernier exemple de qui me paraît
intéressant avant de peut-être prendre
le questionnaire et répondre plus
précisément à vos questions c'est ce que
nous faisons par rapport aux logiciel
d'aide à la prescription et à la
dispensation et nos intervenons sur des
systèmes d'aide à la décision indexée
par médicament ça s'appelle des Sam dans
le jargon que les pharmaciens
connaissent bien et les médecins
connaissent bien également et
en pénurie par exemple très récemment on
peut nous demander ce sont alors
qu'est-ce que c'est que ces systèmes
d'aide
ces systèmes d'aide à la prescription
c'est en fait des pop-up qui
apparaissent dans les logiciels métiers
des médecins quand ils vont prescrire un
médicament et un message peut leur être
délivré et par exemple attention ça peut
être une contre-indication enfin en
temps normal ça peut une aide à la
prescription les alerter sur certaines
choses et là on peut les al sur le bon
usage et en partie où les alternatives
en situation de pénurie pour
l'amoxicilline nous avons fait un tel
logiciel très rapidement de façon à
pouvoir chaque fois que déjà évité
toutes les
mauvaises utilisations puisque voilà il
y en a la pertinence ni soins
elle est déjà favoriser la bonne
utilisation et puis encourager les
alternatives
faire respecter les durées de traitement
etc ces logiciels sont qui sont destinés
à un décret ces petits pop-up qui sont
destinés à être intégrer dans les
logiciels d'aide à la prescription ou à
la dispensation pour les pharmaciens
prescriptions pour les médecins
dispensation pour les pharmaciens
sont extrêmement utiles
en particulier nous on les utilise enfin
il nous semble très intéressants pour ce
qui est la pertinence des prescriptions
évidemment
mais
ils peuvent être difficiles à
implémenter parce qu'il dépend de
évidemment
des éditeurs de logiciels et de leur
rapidité d'intégration de ces outils
numériques d'aide aux professionnels
dans les logiciels voilà donc en fait
nous nous faisons
nous veillons enfin nous publions ces
outils mais ensuite après il faut qu'il
soit intégré dans des logiciels et
peut-être que là il y a quand même à mon
avis des outils qui pourraient être
mieux utilisés
dans cet usage
alors pour ce qui est pour revenir de
façon plus globale au pénurie
ce que nous constatons la chaise c'est
que il y a plusieurs situations de
pénurie bon il y a une citation une
situation qui est
d'augmentation conjoncturelle extrême de
la demande
ça c'est une chose
et
mais c'est un cas un petit peu
particulier il y en a d'autres qui sont
également conjoncturels et qui sont
liées à un problème de survenue dans un
processus de fabrication complexe et
donc qui ne résulte pas ni d'une
stratégie de laboratoire ni d'une
modification de la demande de la dans ce
médicament par exemple pour un vaccin
des vaccins vivants vous savez que c'est
un problème de un processus de
fabrication qui est très complexe et si
il peut y avoir des soucis dans la
chaîne de production et donc on peut se
retrouver
à court de vaccins liés à des problèmes
dans la chaîne de production
et ce n'est pas ce n'est pas rare
d'autres une autre cause par contre qui
est totalement différente de ces deux
premières causes c'est celle qui peuvent
résulter d'un désintérêt des industriels
pour des vaccins anciens alors je suis
vaccin ça pourrait être totalement
superposés aux médicaments et qui sont
considérés comme peu rémunérateurs alors
qu'il conserve une place importante dans
la stratégie thérapeutique qu'elle soit
de traitement ou le vaccination et donc
les indications peuvent rester
importantes pour des vieux médicaments
qui sont
voilà qui sont anciens et qui donc sont
pas du tout les prix des médicaments qui
arrivent sur le marché
et puis enfin il y a une dernière cause
de choix qui sont des choix commerciaux
des laboratoires
de pousser ou pas un médicament je crois
qu'il leur appartiennent dans la
stratégie je dois dire et d'entreprises
et également des choix dans la
répartition des stocks entre pays qui
peuvent qui peuvent évoluer au gré de
nombreux facteurs
alors je ne suis absolument pas en
capacité de vous livrer des éléments
quantitatifs sur chacune de ces
situations
mais quand même on peut constater que
les augmentations encore une fois en
dehors des augmentations de demande
aiguës les processus liés à enfin des
problèmes liés à la fabrication des
produits sont deviennent de plus en plus
fréquents
même si ça ne fait pas partie de nos
missions une des pistes d'amélioration
qui nous semble vraiment
devoir être creusés c'est vraiment la
collaboration européenne entre état
parce qu'il y a ce qui peut être géré au
niveau de la France entre la NSM qui qui
est dont c'est la mission et aider par
toutes les autres agences mais
je dirais que le problème est général et
que une gestion au niveau européen a
davantage de sang de chance d'être
efficace
alors celle-ci cette démarche a déjà
commencé quand même d'abord avec
l'Agence européenne du médicament qui
s'est vu donner des nouvelles missions
sur ce sujet et puis la nouvelle entité
era qui pourrait avoir aussi un rôle à
jouer pour des achats groupés mais là
dans des situations un petit peu
particulières
pour ce qui est de la raison économique
il est clair qu'elle n'est pas
elle ne peut pas être exclue mais que il
est pas du tout certain que
remonter les prix de ces médicaments
suffirait à
je dirais à faire régresser les pénuries
vous savez que les stratégies
d'élaboratoires sont en particulier sur
la production
sont très liées à des phénomènes
mondiaux et donc une augmentation des
prix en France n'auraient qu'un impact
probablement modéré
[Musique]
des stratégies alternatives maintenant
ce qu'il faut quand même savoir c'est ce
sont quand même des raisons très
complexes
multifactorielles et que il y a autant
de situations quasiment que de pénurie
et que donc des solutions globales je
dirais un peu magique malheureusement
voilà
ils sont pas évidentes
puisque les raisons ne sont pas sont
souvent
associées plusieurs
voilà comme propos liminaire je ne
voulais pas prendre davantage de votre
temps et voilà après on peut rentrer
dans vos questions
dans le juge des questions
je ne savais pas qu'on était les
premiers auditionnés donc parce que donc
j'ai pas fait de je dirais de tableaux
de la situation d'abord parce que je
pense qu'elle ne m'appartient pas mais
puis que encore une fois notre rôle à la
HAS est relativement modeste sur ce
domaine
non c'est parfait parce que
exprimer merci beaucoup de ces propos
liminaires déjà assez complet et dense
donc je vais laisser
ma collègue Laurence Cohen rapporteur
nous faire
présenter ces questions et donner ces
éléments de dialogue
merci Madame pour ce propos liminaire et
effectivement il faut bien commencer une
commission d'enquête donc vous êtes les
premières à
commencer donc à nous apporter un
certain nombre de réponses vous avez
reçu un questionnaire qui est
extrêmement complet qui est très fouillé
il y a il y a une douzaine de questions
vous avez vu que vous pouvez y répondre
par écrit parce que effectivement elle
nécessite
d'approfondir chacun des aspects qui
vous sont posés mais à la lumière de ce
que vous avez dit Madame permettez-moi
peut-être d'insister sur quelques points
certains figures d'ailleurs dans les
questions qui vous ont été qui vous ont
été remises mais pas toutes
effectivement vous êtes positionné
d'emblée j'allais dire sur la
problématique vaccinale puisque c'est
votre terrain si je puis dire plus de
compétences par rapport à l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
mais il y a quand même des similitudes
qu'on peut qu'on peut tout à fait
appréhender d'ailleurs que vous avez
souligné entre les pénuries de certains
médicaments et également les pénuries ou
le manque ou etc au niveau au niveau des
des vaccins donc moi j'aimerais
à ce propos vous posez peut-être
quelques quelques questions c'est à dire
que vous avez dit notamment parmi les
causes qu'elles sont multifactorielles
je crois que là on partage tout tous et
toutes ce point de vue parmi les causes
j'avais dit bon il y a la question de
des problèmes sur les chaînes de
production je pense que c'est d'autant
plus vrai pour les vaccins parce que
c'est quand même très très spécialisé il
y a quand même une concentration aussi
une restriction ou je sais pas
rétrécissement plutôt du nombre des
usines qui qui assurent la production du
coup quand il y a un problème sur une
des chaînes et bien ça entraîne des
conséquences qui sont extrêmement
extrêmement importantes donc des
problèmes sur les chaînes de production
des intérêts vous avez dit de la part
des industriels pour certains produits
qui n'apparaissent comme peu rentables
et troisième chose les choix commerciaux
au niveau des laboratoires on peut tout
à fait le transposer ça au niveau au
niveau des des médicaments et je
voudrais peut-être avoir un petit peu un
approfondissement sur
les les
des vaccins et les produits qui
apparaissent comme peu rentables parce
que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
finalement peu rentable on a entendu à
plusieurs reprises le fait de dire que
bon il suffirait
de d'augmenter les prix et puis tout
d'un coup comme par miracle les choses
rentreraient dans l'ordre on voit bien
que c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça
et donc j'aimerais avoir des précisions
sur
qui est-ce qui qui considère que tel ou
tel produit et peut et rentable parce
qu'il y a la rentabilité financière mais
il y a aussi la réponse aux besoins des
populations il peut y avoir une
dichotomie d'ailleurs entre les deux
donc avoir un votre point de vue et
savoir si la HAS est en capacité à les
pouvoirs de pouvoir d'intervention à ce
moment-là pour remettre un peu
un certain cadre par rapport à ces
assez difficultés ensuite j'aimerais
bien aussi peut-être que vous nous
disiez
finalement
c'est le fait que ces choix
puissent
avoir des conséquences plus ou moins
importantes sur les pertes de chance au
niveau au niveau des patientes et des
patients donc avoir là aussi votre votre
expertise concernant ces éléments
troisième
volet peut-être que j'aimerais vous voir
approfondir c'est concernant la
constitution de stocks
parce que on parle beaucoup et on en a
encore parlé là puisqu'on a fait une
visite dans une pharmacie
les stocks donc on dit de moi
sur les médicaments mais en fait on a
appris nous en tant que législateur que
en fait c'est purement déclaratif
c'est-à-dire que on déclare que
effectivement il y a deux mois de stock
mais visiblement
il semblerait j'avais employer un
conditionnel qu'il n'y ait pas de
contrôle et que les déclarations soient
crues et que les stocks soient avérés ou
pas est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
nous donner des éléments sur cette
question particulière et puis
est-ce que
est-ce que au niveau de donc des vaccins
comme comme des médicaments vous nous
avez dit que vous aviez la des
recommandations des des pour essayer de
d'abord d'encourager les bonnes
pratiques bien évidemment éventuellement
de fournir un certain nombre de pistes
on va dire alternatives mais là encore
[Musique]
sur quelle sur quel médicament ou vaccin
particulier il s'agit de traitement qui
sont on va dire anciens considérés comme
peu rentables etc ou non il n'y a pas de
différence entre ces
médicaments là ou ces vaccins là et ceux
qui sont plus récents et plus rentables
est-ce que vous vous voyez vous voyez
des différences et
peut-être enfin une dernière question
c'est
à la lumière de votre expérience en plus
de ce qu'on vient vivre de vivre avec la
covid quels sont de manière plus
pointues les propositions que vous
pourriez faire sur la gestion justement
de ces pénuries parce que de notre point
de vue on pense qu'elles peuvent être
améliorées c'est-à-dire pour ça que on
est sur une commission d'enquête donc
est-ce que vous avez vous des
propositions précises qui vont aussi
dans ce sens je vous remercie
alors pour pour votre
général si elle souhaite
alors pour ce qui est
de la rentabilité d'un produit alors là
je dois vous dire que
je crois pas que je sois la bonne
personne qu'il faut demander
comment un laboratoire jusque son
produit est rentable ou par rentable ce
que je peux moi dire c'est comment
comment est fixé les précieusement sont
fixés les prix des médicaments et quel
est l'intervention de la chaise dans ce
dans cette fixation de prix
d'abord ce que ce que je veux dire c'est
que aujourd'hui on a énormément de
médicaments nouveaux qui arrivent par
rapport à j'ai passé 45 ans à l'hôpital
je peux vous dire que c'est c'est cinq
dernières années n'ont rien à voir avec
les décennies passées et il y a une un
nombre d'innovations et de médicaments
extrêmement important qui arrive mais ce
que je peux dire aussi c'est que ces
médicaments innovants tout à fait
intéressant les vaccins du covid en sont
un bon exemple à Irène messager arrive à
des prix inédits
et que ce soit des vaccins des
anticancéreux des tout ce que vous
voulez des médicaments arrivent à des
prix très très chers nous ne sommes
absolument pas en charge de fixer les
prix mais par contre un la Commission de
la transparence
juge ces produits
une fois qu'ils ont une autorisation de
mise sur le marché par soit la NSM soit
les mains au niveau européen qui
l'autorisation mis sur le marché dit
juste ce pays ce médicament peut être
commercialisé en Europe OK ou en France
en général c'est sur Oui il fait ce
qu'il prétend faire et dans avec des
risques acceptables c'est ce qu'on
appelle la balance bénéficerie ça c'est
du domaine des agences régulatrices que
sont la NSM ou les mains au niveau
européen
ensuite la deuxième question qui se pose
c'est
pour un état donné pour un État membre
dont la France évidemment c'est est-ce
que je souhaite rembourser ce médicament
c'est à dire qu'il soit prise en charge
par la collectivité et dans ces cas-là à
quel tarifs et ça ça s'appuie sur c'est
le rôle de la chas par sa commission de
la transparence qui a deux critères un
qui évalue le service médical rendu je
vais pas vous détailler tout ce qui
rentre comme comme critère pour évaluer
et qui dit oui ce médicament bon un
service médical rendu faible puisqu'il y
a trois taux de remboursement
nul donc non remboursé faible modéré ou
élevé
beaucoup de médicaments étaient encore
quand même pris à 100% pour les patients
en ALD même quand ils ont un taux de
remboursement plus régulier donc déjà
c'est la première chose que cette
commission dit faut-il ou pas rembourser
et à quel taux et puis le deuxième va
critère c'est l'amélioration du service
médical rendu c'est à dire ce produit
qui arrive comment se situe-t-il par
rapport aux anciens est-ce que dans la
stratégie thérapeutique il importe un
mieux pour le patient parce que tout ce
qui arrive qui est innovo n'est pas
forcément une inhibation
utile au patient et ce critère là
s'appuie sur deux choses la quantité des
faits du nouveau produit comparé comparé
aux anciens et la qualité de la
démonstration avec lequel le laboratoire
vient or c'est important de le savoir
avec cette
énorme activité d'innovation de nouveaux
médicaments
avec le fait que ces médicaments
arrivent de plus en plus vite auprès je
dirais des patients enfin et
l'accès aux patients soit accéléré vous
avez en France des processus qui
permettent même de les prendre en charge
dans des maladies graves
en amont de la même c'est à dire c'est
ce qui a remplacé les atténues c'était
les autorisations d'accès précoce donc
qui peuvent être un an avant la même sur
des données très préliminaires et
ensuite avec des prises en charge
également en accéléré c'est et l'Emma
qui donne des im de plus en plus
conditionnel
c'est-à-dire que avant d'avoir des
critères durs je dirais que
le degré d'incertitude avec lequel
arrive ces médicaments à la Commission
de la transparence n'arrête pas
d'augmenter donc c'est pour ça que cet
asmr varie selon à la fois la quantité
des faits l'amélioration et de l'effet
et la qualité de la preuve qui parfois
est défectueuse
avec cette asmr ce sms avec ces deux
indicateurs qu'ensuite le CEPS va fixer
les prix d'un médicament voilà donc il
va négocier de la négociation avec les
industriels qu'il a n'appartiennent plus
à la S et qui va fixer les prix alors
évidemment un nouveau médicament qui
arrive aujourd'hui avec des innovations
risque d'être valorisées de façon
beaucoup plus importante qu'un
médicament ancien
qui a été évalué il y a quelques années
dans un contexte totalement différent
donc ça je dirais que l'intervention de
la chaise sur le prix c'est là qu'elle
se situe ensuite la négociation
se passe ailleurs alors après est-ce
qu'il faut des questions qui peuvent se
poser c'est qu'il faut intégrer dans ces
critères le fait que par exemple le prix
le médicament soit fabriqué en France
est-ce qu'il faut intégrer d'autres
critères dans cette négociation de prix
ça
c'est plutôt
du ressort de ceps voilà c'est pour vous
situer exactement ce que fait chacun
parce que je crois que c'est important
que que le rôle de chacun voilà
Fabienne vous voulez peut-être compléter
oui enfin juste peut-être pour pour
appeler que dans certains cas précis où
on peut pas évidemment vous dire parce
qu'on n'est pas dans les comptes des
entreprises pour savoir ce qui est
rentable etc et on veut surtout pas y
être mais
si vous voulez en revanche que ce qu'on
peut constater c'est qu'il y a des vieux
produits qui sont sur le marché depuis
très longtemps et dont le prix est
relativement bas et que potentiellement
j'imagine mais ça c'est les discussions
que le ministère doit avoir avec les
industriels il est possible que un
certain nombre de coups qui lui ait
augmenté ne soit pas totalement reflétée
parce qu'il y a des très vieux
médicaments dans des niches parfois ça
arrive voilà mais peut-être que sur ce
point en tout cas
c'est clair que de toute façon c'est pas
du tout dans le ressort de la Haute
Autorité de Santé de décret avec
lesquels on fait des évaluations qui
doivent être vraiment fait selon les
critères scientifiques et médicaux comme
Dominique vient de l'expliquer
alors pour ce qui est des pertes de
chances elles sont indéniable quand il
manque d'un anticancéreux qui même s'il
n'est pas tout récent fait partie des
protocoles de chimiothérapie des
patients et qu'il faut trouver des
alternatives
quand il s'agit d'infection qui manque
un antibiotique alors que on sait que ce
germe est sensible à cet antibiotique
quand on parle de médicaments
d'anesthésie réanimation je parlais du
midazolam pendant la crise mais bon ça
peut être hors crise
les traitements des greffés par exemple
sont particulièrement sensibles parce
que c'est des traitements qui ne peuvent
pas être arrêtés c'est des traitements
au long cours mais qui ne peuvent pas
être interrompus voilà donc il y a des
risques il y a des pertes de chances qui
sont plus importantes évidemment plus la
maladie est sévère ou plus le traitement
est indispensable je veux dire mais on
ne peut pas le nier
voilà ça fait partie alors quand
évidemment ce que nous là nous sommes
sollicités c'est pour dans certains cas
particuliers trouver des alternatives
qui justement limite les pertes de
chance c'est à dire pour minimiser au
plus ces pertes de chance
vous m'interrogez sur les stocks alors
là nous ne sommes vraiment pas en charge
des stocks
nous n'avons pas vraiment de vision ce
qu'on peut simplement dire c'est que ça
dépend aussi il y a des inspections qui
sont faites chez les grossistes
répartiteurs par les ARS et donc
en tout cas c'est plutôt eux qui
auraient une vision sur l'état de ses
stocks en tout cas où est-ce que vous
ont dit c'est pharmacien en effet sur le
fait que ce soit déclaratif et que ça
n'est pas forcément inspecté ça peut
l'être et si vous voulez l'inspection de
tous la chaîne grossiste très partitaire
qui alimentent les pharmaciens elle les
pharmacies
c'est dans les ARS les pharmaciens
inspecteurs qui sont en charge de cette
inspection mais vous pourrez poser la
question à la NSM qui surveille
alors donc qui est pas d'ambiguïté sur
les questions que j'ai posées c'est à
dire que
je n'ai pas de
je n'ai pas pensé que l'agence que la
Haute Autorité pardon de santé avait des
compétences là-dessus la question que je
vous ai posée n'est pas celle-ci
la question est plutôt à avec votre
expérience
et avec votre expertise
de votre point de vue à vous pas celui
de l'agence ni de l'ARS ni on va les
interroger il n'y a pas de problème mais
par rapport à vous vous qu'est-ce que
vous pensez en terme de stock qui
pourrait sécuriser c'est juste ça
peut-être que vous n'avez pas vous
n'avez pas suffisamment de voilà de
recul ou je ne sais pas enfin je ne veux
pas qualifier mais c'est plus par
rapport à vous parce que vous avez quand
même un retour en tout cas au niveau des
vaccins et vous pouvez à peu près avec
voilà
peut-être pas de façon exhaustive mais
pouvoir dire que on serait plus sécurisé
si voilà mais peut-être pas mais voilà
qu'on reste sur c'est votre champ de
compétences que je que j'interroge pas
celui
déjà la législation 21 avait prévu des
stocks si mes souvenirs sont bons
c'était quatre mois pour les médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeurs
et donc enfin c'était alors ça se
limiter au produit qui avait fait
l'objet de pénurie
dans les deux ans précédant donc c'est
peut-être pas suffisant mais en tout cas
la démarche avait démarré à ce moment-là
pour essayer
je dirais de cadrer les stocks
nécessaires donc peut-être faut-il
élargir cette disposition et je crois
que enfin nous participons à un comité
interministériel sur le sujet qui
cherche des solutions et en effet la
déjà
l'authentification de quel médicament
lesquels enfin la constitution d'une
liste je dirais des médicaments
prioritaires pour lequel il serait
important d'avoir ces stocks va
va être constituée
peut-être que alors il faut voir si
c'est les critères les modalités de
définition de ce qu'on appelle les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeurs est-ce qui permettent de couvrir
l'ensemble dont les dans la rupture
pourrait constituer une perte de chance
ça il faut vraiment ça mérite d'être
travaillé je crois que ça va l'être et
voilà nous participerons à ces travaux
ensuite
cette législation est-ce qu'elle est
appliquée déjà alors en fait peut-être
les tentes mais est-ce qu'elle est
appliquée et là en effet bon c'est dur
sort peut-être d'inspection
et puis de pénalité le problème c'est
là c'est vraiment un peu personnel mais
c'est le problème c'est que les les
industries pharmaceutiques les
industriels sont des compagnies
mondiales maintenant multinationales
pour lequel le marché français
n'est pas un sujet je veux dire nous
représentons quand même relativement peu
de choses par rapport à leur production
mondiale et donc il est pas certain que
nos mesures nationales et un impact
important sur sur leur stratégie
mondiale et par exemple
c'est pour ça que je disais pour les
prix pour l'augmentation des prix c'est
ça peut-être une solution mais partielle
parce que évidemment j'imagine je ne
suis pas un industriel mais j'imagine
que centraliser complètement avoir
qu'une chaîne de production
représente des économies majeures pour
un industriel alors que le petit plus
qu'on va donner
voilà est-ce qu'il compensera voilà et
je dirais même quand on met des
pénalités si le gain de productivité
majeur que représente nos pénalités pour
un industriel il est possible aussi que
ce soit difficile
de se situer à ce niveau là voilà donc
je crois que en effet il y a la loi dit
qu'il faut des stocks il faut vérifier
que la liste de médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majorit bien complète il
faut qu'elle couvre toutes les
situations délicates il faut faire
respecter cette loi par des inspections
après
qu'elle va être le résultat final voilà
pas forcément évident il faut pouvoir
quand même ce sont des maintenant les
entreprises pharmaceutiques sont des
multinationales
qui ont des intérêts mondiaux et je
dirais de façon plus générale que c'est
pour ça que la réponse européenne est
importante parce que le marché européen
avec des systèmes de santé très
solidaires comme un qui prennent
beaucoup de choses en charge peuvent là
avoir un poids que nationalement nous ne
pouvons pas voir et c'est vrai c'est
vrai aussi pour pour les médicaments
innovants c'est pas vrai que pour les
médicaments anciens donc c'est pour ça
que là
l'Europe entière serait probablement
plus forte pour lutter
pour imposer un certain nombre de
contraintes que la France toute
je sais pas si j'ai totalement répondu à
votre question mais
voilà
alors les bonnes pratiques
ben oui alors ça c'est un sujet qui
existe même en dehors des pénuries sur
lequel nous c'est un petit peu nous
travaillons beaucoup les bonnes
pratiques et la pertinence d'utilisation
des médicaments mais je dirais qu'elle
se évidemment elle prend une acuité
encore plus particulière quand tu es une
tension sur un produit donc évidemment
voilà là en effet nous sommes à
travailler avec les professionnels pour
trouver des alternatives et pour
de façon plus générale sur la pertinence
des prescriptions en France on a de très
gros progrès à faire et je parle pas des
médicaments en tension là je parle
globalement on a de très gros progrès à
faire
[Musique]
certains pays qu'on nous cite souvent en
exemple comme l'Allemagne
certes payent peut-être mieux ces
professionnels de santé mais ils ont des
contraintes de prescription qui sont
beaucoup plus fortes c'est à dire que il
y a des recommandations ils sont censés
bien sûr la médecine et absolument pas
une science exacte c'est-à-dire que
c'est pour ça que ce sont jamais des
recommandations c'est du droit mou c'est
pas des ordures c'est parce que les
situations cliniques en médecine sont
tellement variées qu'il faut vraiment
laisser la latitude aux professionnels
d'apprécier
la situation clinique mais néanmoins
je sais mes collègues également quand
ils sont hors des clous que pour une
prescription
s'ils ne le justifie pas et bien le
patient n'est pas remboursé donc je peux
vous dire que ils sont beaucoup moins
souvent des clous et qu'il le justifie
donc voilà alors ça c'est une réflexion
générale mais évidemment c'est d'autant
plus important sur des médicaments
pas que pour ça utiliser à bon escient
les antibiotiques vous savez que ça a
d'autres répercussions sur
environnementales qui sont extrêmement
importantes
parce que je vois que en terme
d'horaires on
c'est bon
je suis je vous remercie beaucoup je
vous remercie beaucoup non non
donc merci beaucoup de vos réponses donc
on va je propose qu'on passe la parole
aux membres de la commission qui
souhaite vous interroger donc j'ai reçu
dans l'ordre les demandes de questions
de Madame borsche au fond de teint
madame Humbert monsieur Milon et Madame
arrivée si vous en êtes d'accord vous
posez les questions les uns après les
autres en faisant court contenu de vos
délais voilà de façon à ce que les
premières réponses puissent se faire
voilà merci madame la présidente madame
la présidente Madame la Directrice
Générale mes chers collègues merci
d'avoir pour vos propos liminaires vous
l'avez compris vous ouvrez les travaux
de notre commission d'enquête
je vais vous poser directement la
question pour gagner du temps alors
comme vous le savez bien sûr le cancer
demeure la cause la principale cause la
première cause d'ailleurs en France de
décès chez l'homme et la deuxième chez
femme quant aux enfants ils sont près de
500 à ne pas remporter le combat contre
la maladie chaque année et face à une
population vieillissante l'augmentation
des cancers est quasiment mathématique
et pourtant les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes puisque de 10 à 15% des
médicaments en pénurie sont utilisés
dans le cadre de traitement contre le
cancer alors pour pallier à ce manque
l'Agence nationale de la sécurité du
médicament et des produits de santé bien
d'autoriser donc les pharmacies on en a
parlé à produire elle-même de la
mobiline mais à titre exceptionnel et
temporaire c'était l'objet de la visite
de ce jour la Ligue de contrôle le
cancer réclame la création d'un
établissement public du médicament qui
travaillerait de manière coordonnée dans
le cadre d'une participation publique
privée je rappelle que trois
cancérologues sur 4 ont déjà été
confrontés à une pénurie de médicaments
pour leur patient donc ma question est
la suivante pensez-vous que la création
d'un tel établissement permettrait une
meilleure gestion des stocks et ainsi
qu'une meilleure anticipation je vous
remercie
de une petite remarque et puis deux
questions très courtes la petite
remarque c'est aussi beaucoup de temps
gaspillés pour dans le milieu
pharmaceutique
voilà beaucoup de temps médical
gaspillés mais beaucoup de temps en
pharmacie
idem deux questions au regard de ce que
vous avez dit en introduction vous avez
évoqué les logiciels d'aide à la
prescription dans quel délai moyen
sont-ils intégré au logiciels des
professionnels de santé est-ce que vous
le savez parce que ça doit vous demander
du temps de l'énergie vous allez
produire quelque chose de qualité mais
si ça arrive dans les logiciels trois
mois après ben c'est un peu un peu
dommage et deuxième question vous avez
dit
ce pomme méchant non plus comme question
c'est pas c'est pour vous épargner du
temps
[Rires]
excusez-nous deuxième question vous avez
évoqué le M1 donc l'Agence européenne du
médicament et vous avez dit que elle
s'était vu donner de nouvelles missions
est-ce que de façon très courte nous
dire quelles étaient ses nouvelles
missions je vous remercie
si c'est pas court vous ne répondrez par
écrit alors monsieur
merci
je vais j'ai pas de question
j'ai deux observations à faire d'abord
madame la Présidente
la première c'est que j'ai reçu
l'invitation pour cette réunion
d'aujourd'hui hier c'est un peu court je
suppose que c'est peut-être parce
qu'elle n'est pas présent la première
réunion j'aimerais les recevoir à
l'avance parce que la Commission
m'intéresse beaucoup et première chose
la deuxième chose et on est très heureux
de vous compter parmi nous
je suis pas sûr ça durera mais on verra
ça par la suite
vous avez dit
Laurence a dit que
vos invités recevaient les questions
je faisais en sorte quand je prisais les
commissions que les commissaires
reçoivent les questions en même temps
que les rapporteurs et donc que les gens
ont questionnent ça pourrait être très
intéressant que nous puissions recevoir
les questions en même temps de manière à
pouvoir les étudier et à pouvoir
un peu plus titiller nos invités donc je
je prends bonne note de vos remarques
chers collègues et que je prends avec
beaucoup de comment dire d'humilité et
auquel je souscris pleinement et
entièrement soyez-en assurés je n'en
doute pas sur le restant et j'ai une
proposition à faire bon
j'ai bien écouté ce qui a dit madame la
Présidente Autorité de Santé je m'étais
d'ailleurs posé la question de savoir
pourquoi c'était la Haute Autorité santé
qui était convoquée dans une première
réunion dans la mesure où la pénurie de
médicaments n'est pas directement dans
ses compétences et j'aurais aimé
j'aimerais
[Musique]
un tour de table de questions auprès de
la présidente et de la République
mais je veux dire j'aimerais j'aimerais
revoir madame la Présidente
dans quelques temps quand on aura déjà
eu plus d'éléments sur la pénurie et sur
la sur la façon dont
les observations qui ont été faites par
elle de sont intéressantes en
particulier celles que vous avez faite
dans la prison sur l'impact de la France
par rapport à la stratégie mondiale des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques je crois
que c'est important et je suis d'accord
avec vous sur la fête qu'il faut donner
plus de pouvoir aller ma en particulier
mais
je pense et je vous fais une proposition
madame la rapporteur ma dernière
présidente que il faudra ne plus
convoquer des agences un par un parce
qu'il nous disent des choses qu'on est
bien obligé de gober puisqu'on a pas en
face ce qu'ils doivent dire le contraire
et par exemple j'aimerais que si on
convoque le CEPS on covoit qu'en face
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques pour
qu'il puisse discuter et que nous on
puisse retirer la substantifique well
donc j'ai pas de question directe je
vous remercie madame présidente
d'avoir fait l'effort de venir à cette
commission et j'espère vous revoir après
que nous serons plus instruits
donc madame la présidente madame
directrice évidemment ne sont pas
parjures et bien évidemment
nous ne faisons pas preuve d'une naïveté
excessive et elle n'utilise pas
évidemment des paroles qui sont
inappropriées ou inexactes
merci madame la Présidente
par avance je tiens à m'excuser je dois
partir à 30 donc j'espère que la réponse
par courtoisie aussi à votre égard je
vous prie de m'excuser vous avez bien
dit que en fait vous réalisiez des
évaluations
médico-économiques qui servent de base à
la fixation
des prix enfin dans le cadre du CEPS qui
négocie mais quand on parle de
d'évaluation médico-économique on est
bien obligé à un moment donné
d'introduire des éléments économiques or
la rentabilité
du médicament fait partie de ces de ces
critères là et je vous avais dit à juste
titre que l'industrie pharmaceutique
était une industrie mondialisée mais on
a une kérielle de PME qui travaille
souvent sur la production de médicaments
génériques et qui eux aujourd'hui qui
elle aujourd'hui sont en grande
difficulté par rapport à ce prix de
médicaments trop bas
est-ce qu'il faut pas complètement
revoir enfin ça c'est votre expérience
indépendamment de vol incompétence de
l'autorité est-ce qu'il faudrait pas
revoir complètement cette politique de
fixation des prix en fonction de la
nature des médicaments de Magic
médicament d'imatures d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur et puis des
médicaments innovants parce que je pense
que très on ne peut pas raisonner de la
même manière à la fois sur le plan
scientifique et sur le plan
économique
avec ces deux types de médicaments et la
deuxième question qui avait envie de
vous poser c'est que si on poursuit le
raisonnement
à un moment donné on va se poser la
question du prix et si on se pose la
question du prix du médicament c'est
aussi par rapport à la santé publique
un enjeu de santé publique est-ce que on
pourrait pas imaginer
une production un accord partenariat
public privé un peu comme les américains
l'ont fait avec avec le projet Civica
qui associe près de 900 hôpitaux publics
à la fabrication de médicaments et qui
donc
finalement distingue ce qui est du
domaine de la recherche et de
l'innovation et ce qui est du domaine du
médicament pas basique c'est pas le
terme exact mais en tout cas voilà je
pense qu'on est arrivé à un moment où la
politique de santé doit être
complètement revue et réfléchi
y compris en intégrant la question
européenne dans cette dans cette
organisation là je vous remercie
vous partez alors je dirais que je me
suis mal fait comprendre parce que ce
que dont j'ai parlé il existe une
évaluation spécifique pour l'évaluation
médico-économique des produits qui sait
receps pour la fixation du prix mais qui
ne se fait que pour les médicaments
qu'on des impacts budgétaires très
importants dont j'ai parlé avant c'est
une évaluation médicale scientifique
pure qu'est-ce qu'apporte le médicament
pour la santé du patient et qu'est-ce
qu'il apporte en plus par rapport au
reste et la France par rapport à
d'autres pays a voulu totalement
dissocier cette étude scientifique
médicale et c'est pour ça que la chaise
est une autorité publique indépendante
aussi de l'évaluation médico-économique
et de la du coup pour pour les
régulateurs je dirais ce qui c'est pas
que c'est pas important mais voilà il y
a des pays comme l'Angleterre qui
associent les deux et qui n'évaluent un
produit que sur du médico-économique ce
n'est pas le cas en France et a priori
dans le nouveau règlement européen
d'évaluation des produits de santé ce
n'est pas le cas non plus c'est à dire
que là c'est vraiment une évaluation
médicale donc ça je tenais les ensuite
faut-il changer la politique de fixation
des prix alors vraiment ça dépasse mes
compétences je pense que c'est c'est
vraiment un problème très complexe
qui vraiment avec beaucoup de d'aspects
qui ne sont vraiment très peu médicales
je le crains vous dites que les
médicaments innovants sont très
différents des anciens médicaments c'est
vrai c'est vrai puis c'est surtout que
on a vu exploser le prix des nouveaux
médicaments je veux dire quand les
médicaments de l'hépatite sont arrivés
souvenez-vous
vu que s'il y avait des populaires une
population très importante à traiter les
prix de 200.000 euros paraissaient
astronomiques moi quand je suis arrivé à
la chasse l'innovation la plus chère
quand je l'ai vu arriver elle coûtait un
million d'euros le traitement c'était
voilà là maintenant on voit des produits
à 3 millions d'euros donc je veux dire
on voit bien que les coûts les prix des
innovations
n'ont rien à voir avec les coups de
développement ou de recherche et sont
basés sur autre chose qui est la vérité
à payer des plus riches de ce monde et
ensuite la France enfin je dirais qu'on
est bien obligé c'est cranter comme ça
et on est bien obligé de suivre sinon
les laboratoires ne nous livreront pas
les médicaments donc bon ça c'est des
considérations donc après faut-il pour
certains produits produire en France
est-ce que les expériences qu'on a fait
dans d'autres domaines ont été
concluants ou pas ça mérite d'être
évalué
on a des
pharmacies centrales on en a trois en
pharmacie des hôpitaux de l'Assistance
publique on a trois
il y en a trois
voilà
exactement est-ce qu'il faut leur donner
un autre rôle pour certains produits là
encore il y a énormément de facteurs qui
rentrent en cause
enfin en question et je n'aurais pas eu
de réponse univoque
toujours est-il que c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on paye très très cher les
nouveaux médicaments qui arrivent
faut-il payer très cher aussi des
anciens et qu'est-ce qui reste de
l'ONDAM pour le reste
ça finit par devenir une question
globale c'est-à-dire on voit bien que
nos hôpitaux actuellement n'ont plus
suffisamment de ressources donc
quelle est la velléité à payer et à quel
prix mais en sachant que quand même il
faut le savoir les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques si le prix ne leur
convient pas ils vont ailleurs je veux
dire on est plus c'est plus des marchés
captifs
donc c'est un risque aussi qu'on veut
pas faire courir à nos patients de ne
pas avoir accès à une innovation à un
médicament et c'est pour ça qu'on les
paye si cher
voilà alors pour ce qui est du temps des
pharmaciens
je partage totalement c'est à dire que
tout ça demande beaucoup de temps aux
professionnels de santé en général voilà
je n'ai pas d'idées précis sur le temps
moyen d'implantation par les éditeurs je
sais que c'est une implante pas dans des
délais raisonnables ils ont des
pénalités mais quand même temps
on n'a pas sur les logiciels sur la
question voilà sur les logiciels
nous n'avons pas de retour je crois
personne ne recense exactement est-ce
que quelqu'un est chargé d'un
recensement
et d'un contrôle de ses délais je ne
suis pas sûr
l'image en avait déjà parlé je crois
qu'en effet les masses et vu confier des
missions
dans le cadre justement comme la NSM la
gestion de des produits en tension mais
au niveau européen et que les travaux
n'ont pas démarré encore mais je pense
que c'est en effet à l'échelon européen
qu'on peut avoir un petit poids sur les
industriels et très peu à l'échelon
national et puis
puis un établissement public du
médicament j'ai répondu c'est vraiment
une problématique complexe mais sur
cette point là je suis sûr que Fabienne
dans ses anciennes fonctions puisqu'elle
a dirigé la NSM par le passé a peut-être
d'autres éléments donc
c'est vrai que c'est important de
à vrai dire bon c'est dommage parce que
là c'est une triste qui a posé la
question et est parti
voilà c'est ça mais
non mais pour que je lui pose la
question d'exactement ce qu'elle
entendait par un établissement public
privé du médicament enfin ça me
paraissait vraiment très large donc je
ne sais pas vraiment répondre à cette
question tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est puisque j'étais dans d'autres
fonctions mais en tout cas j'étais dans
des fonctions ministérielles quand la HS
a été créé et donc la Commission de la
transparence et l'acné d'IMS qui est la
commission pour les dispositifs médicaux
ont quitté l'ancienne hassaps pour créer
la HS avec en s'agglomérant à la NES
ce qui est ce que ce que le législateur
à l'époque avait en tête c'est vraiment
de d'assurer l'indépendance de
l'expertise scientifique du
remboursement et donc d'avoir vraiment
une expertise scientifique qui soit
transparente
rigoureuse faites sur des bases claires
accessibles à tous et qui permettrait à
toutes les professionnels toutes les
parties prenantes les citoyens les
professionnels de santé d'avoir une
visibilité sur les critères qui
permettaient ou non d'admettre un
produit au remboursement et voir de le
désinscrire également de le radis et du
remboursement comme ça a été fait assez
récemment sur l'homéopathie notamment où
la le rôle est l'indépendance de l'achat
sont été primordiaux pour garantir si
vous voulez que les critères selon
lesquels la Haute Autorité de Santé
avait évalué ces produits et avait rendu
son avis en donnant un service médical
rendu insuffisant pour absence de preuve
d'efficacité justement était accessible
à tous et que en tout cas que ce n'était
pas une décision politique mais que
c'était bien une décision scientifique
et je pense que de ce point de vue là il
est important de préserver surtout après
la période qu'on vient de passer avec le
covid et
qui vont sans doute
sur un certain nombre de sujets
sensibles on le voit encore aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est important de
préserver certains dépendances
scientifiques et de la détacher
justement de tout influence je dirais
globale puisque
l'admission au remboursement enfin
l'admission la mise sur le marché et les
autorisations sur le marché mais vous
européens se font au regard des textes
européens donc qui agglomèrent quand
même ce que veulent 27 États membres
jadis 28 d'ailleurs pour les textes en
vigueur aujourd'hui et donc je pense que
c'est important si vous voulez de
distinguer ces deux sujets puisque
effectivement la liberté de circulation
des biens et des services c'est dans les
traités européens donc c'est important
que en termes d'accès au marché cette
autorisation soit européenne en revanche
les systèmes de remboursement comme vous
le savez sont très très différents
ne répond pas aux mêmes critères n'ont
pas les mêmes logiques ni même histoires
et ont beaucoup de complexité je pense
que c'est important d'avoir un
institution
comme la Haute autorité qui permet de
donner une évaluation indépendante
scientifique de qu'est-ce qu'on retient
pour la mission de remboursement donc
voilà pour répondre à cette question
je dirais peut-être juste pour juste une
précision par rapport à
enfin aux éléments que vous avez donné
moi effectivement je trouve que c'est
extrêmement important qui est pas
d'évaluation médico-économique il y en a
une mais indépendant
de l'évaluation pardon de la Haute
Autorité de santé ça me paraît très
important et en même temps vous nous
avez dit cette évaluation de la de la
Haute Autorité donc qui se base sur je
vais le dire le service de santé rendu
voilà
vous dites comme ça il permet de la
transparer mais ce cet évaluation de la
Haute Autorité de santé elle est
directement communiquée
pour l'évaluation des prix où elle est
parce que je n'ai pas vérifié cet
élément là ou bien elle se trouve en
toute transparence comme on peut voir
dans les comptes rendus de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
est-ce que vous est-ce que votre
évaluation
transparente d'un point de vue j'allais
dire tout venant c'est cette question là
que je n'ai pas avant que vous répondiez
on va prendre la dernière question de
Madame Muller Braun et les autres fois
on demandera vraiment à tout le monde de
ce signaler dès le départ ça sera plus
simple pour nos interlocuteurs merci
Madame ma Présidente c'est une question
qui m'est venue en vous écoutant en fait
concernant par exemple
l'homéopathie vous disiez que c'était
bien un regard scientifique et non pas
un regard politique alors la question
que je me posais c'est est-ce que ce
regard scientifique il est le même pour
toute l'Europe puisque si on parle vous
avez évoqué l'homéopathie il y a des
pays européens qui qui ont un autre
regard et si c'est un regard
scientifique on peut imaginer que il y a
pas de frontière et la science étant
voilà c'est ma question est vous l'avez
compris oui oui tout à fait alors moi
j'ai deux réponses alors d'abord
l'analyse médico-économique elle est
aussi à la chas mais elle est totalement
séparée une commission indépendante
et donc ils ont écouté tous les débats
de la commission etc donc c'est
accessible sur notre site à qui le veut
tout totalement transparent et je crois
que ça c'est extrêmement important parce
que voilà on peut ne pas être d'accord
avec une
appréciation mais elle est collégiale et
complètement transparente avec des
phases contradictoires c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des experts évidemment les
commissions peuvent pas avoir toutes les
expertises toutes les spécialités
médicales sont par présentées on
additionne aussi des experts extérieurs
et puis si l'industriel n'est pas
contente son appréciation il revient en
face contradictoire il amène aussi des
experts et donc voilà l'ensemble du
processus est totalement transparent je
crois que ça c'est vraiment très
important le regard scientifique c'est
un regard scientifique et j'ajouterai
qu'il y a des patients dans toutes nos
commissions et qu'ils ont un regard
extrêmement pertinent sur l'appréciation
des des médicaments et des innovations
et qu'ils ont vraiment tout un rôle à
jouer extrêmement important d'abord
parce que sur leur vision des
traitements ou des améliorations sur la
qualité de vie qui sont parfois moins
pris en compte par les patients les
médecins qui voient surtout
l'allongement de la durée de vie ou la
guérison je dirais ou la
partielle ou totale mais en tout cas le
regard des patients sur les traitements
sur le comment il les supporte sur les
effets secondaires sur leursquels la
meilleure action de leurs qualités de
vie sont extrêmement importantes donc je
dirais que cette transparence
cette participation des patients est
très très importante alors ce regard
scientifique alors je dirais sur le
homéopathie on est les seuls le seul
pays à avoir évalué scientifiquement le
PO homéopathie sur la demande d'Agnès
Buzin à l'époque qui pour je dirais
mettre fin à des controverses voulaient
qu'ils évaluation et voilà nous ce que
nous avons dit humblement aux personnes
qui parce que nous avions fait une
réputation publique dans nos méthodes en
particulier pour les vaccins mais aussi
certains médicaments très sensibles
socialement sociétalement nous ont des
consultations publiques et nous avons
dit nous disons pas que c'est inefficace
pour certains patients nous disons qu'il
n'y a pas de preuve d'efficacité dans ce
que nous avons pu réunir à la fois dans
la littérature extensive vraiment et à
la fois dans dans ce que ce que nous ont
dit les professionnels de santé
mais ce regard alors sinon en dehors
d'un sujet particulier comme ça notre
analyse elle est basée sur des dossiers
déposés par les laboratoires des
dossiers d'études de différentes phases
il y a des phases 1 2 3 etc et ces
dossiers là ce sont les mêmes en général
pour tous les pays de l'Europe c'est à
dire que et les critères d'après alors
les méthodes d'évaluation sont pas les
mêmes c'est tout le travail qui est en
train d'être fait en ce moment par mes
équipes c'est travailler avec les autres
pays européens pour avoir une démarche
commune une évaluation qui convienne à
l'ensemble des pays européens c'est pas
si simple mais en tout cas ce regard sur
le plan du regard scientifique de
l'appréciation scientifique
il peut être il peut être mis en commun
après il restera à chaque pays ce qu'on
appelle le jugement de valeur
c'est-à-dire et ce qu'il veut rembourser
ou pas et le prix qu'il est prêt à payer
ça c'est national mais l'analyse
scientifique des dossiers peut être
partagée
merci beaucoup de ces réponses
assez complète vraiment madame la
Présidente et Madame
est-ce que vous souhaitez porter
d'autres éléments à la connaissance de
la Commission dans
ce que nous avons pas forcément abordé
toutes les questions et à titre
personnel je je
j'ai juste une un questionnement c'est
sur la question de la saisine sur le
service médical rendu et l'amélioration
du service médical rendu
est-ce que c'est une auto saisie mais ce
qui vous arrive de vous autos saisir un
peu comme ça parce que vous sentez qu'un
sujet pourrait émerger ou est-ce qu'il
faut qu'il y ait une saisine un peu
officiel sur les sujets et est-ce qu'il
y a des saisies ne systématiques à
l'arrivée d'un d'un nouveau médicament
puisque
en réalité votre votre avis est
essentiel on l'a vécu pendant la période
de la covid la grosse phase épidémique
les vaccinations mais on voit bien que
ce que vous apportez est à regard
différent et justement parce que c'est
pas exactement la même chose que le
regard économique et la question du
remboursement
vous participez pleinement politique de
santé publique et notamment de du soin
tout à l'heure je dirais qu'il y a deux
types d'entrée dans nos travaux tout ce
qui est évaluation des produits ou des
actes médicaux en vue d'un remboursement
alors pour les produits de santé ce sont
des industriels qui déposent un dossier
chez nous et nous évaluons un produit
nous ne pouvons l'évaluer d'ailleurs que
quand un industriel nous dépose nos
produits et nous demande de l'évaluer
voilà donc ça c'est une entrée par
contre pour tout ce qui est
recommandation de votre pratique
pertinence etc nous travaillons sur ces
unes du ministère des associations des
conseils nationaux professionnels et
pour certains sujets en auto saisie pour
les médicaments il y a quand même des
travaux qui sont en auto saisine c'est
quand nous voulons réévaluer toute une
classe de médicaments il y a eu par
exemple des arrivées successives de des
améliorations des nouveaux médicaments
en masse et nous voulons avoir à nouveau
une vue globale sur le traitement des
différentes phases d'un traitement
diabète etc quand les choses ont
suffisamment changé et quand nous y
arrivons parce que ça demande beaucoup
de ressources et que vu le nombre de
dossiers qui arrivent on a beaucoup de
mal et pour le vaccin je ne vous
cacherai pas qu'on a beaucoup de mal à
assurer quand une ni y arriverions nous
prenons le temps de revoir complètement
une classe thérapeutique et ça sera la
stratégie d'utilisation de chacun et de
chaque médicament et ça ça demande du
temps c'est très utile aux patient et
aux prescripteurs
je dirais juste pour terminer que il y a
de pour moi il y a deux aspects
différents il y a la prévention des
pénuries avec des aspects industriels
qui qui sont complexes et qui me
dépassent beaucoup enfin on peut essayer
de gérer et d'essayer de prévenir mais
il faut vraiment se mettre tous autour
de la table et travailler pour voir
comment on peut limiter je dirais et
puis après il y a la gestion de la
pénurie après et où là on est fait plus
on anticipe les choses et mieux on se
porte parce que au moins on est des
processus de travail coordonnés de façon
à apporter une réponse rapide aux
professionnels et aux patients et donc
pour la gestion de la pénurie elle-même
pas pour l'anticipation mais pour le bon
pour l'anticipation aussi la pour la
prévention l'anticipation est importante
aussi mais je dirais que
l'anticipation de la gestion de la
pénurie de l'information des
professionnels
des outils pour arriver à leur faciliter
le travail dans ces conditions là et
extrêmement importante que là on a des
progrès tout ça fait
juste pardon
le cas de la prévention des pénurie jour
où je vois complètement mais
quand on demande au ministre de faire de
la prévention de la pénurie ils ont tous
le syndrome Bachelot quand même
souvenez-vous achat N1 on avait beaucoup
acheté de vaccins beaucoup acheter de
tamiflux beaucoup acheter etc qui n'ont
finalement pas servi à qui on a reproché
ensuite à une bise d'avoir trop acheté
donc il y a une limite à tout c'est pour
ça je dis que c'est très complexe c'est
que je me garde bien de donner une
solution univoque parce que je pense que
c'est en effet très complexe
il faut pas mettre de l'argent non plus
dans ce qui va passer servir voilà et
puis les process de industriels sont ce
qu'ils sont
je ne sais pas si c'est un établissement
public qui est le plus
âme dans c'est la mission je vraiment
c'est très compliqué
il y a quand même les anticipations
classiques les crises épidémiques
hivernales et notamment
concernant les nourrissons ça fait
partie des et les besoins en corticoïdes
en gouttes par exemple pour ne citer que
cette question là c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut anticiper donc il y a le
conjoncturel et il y a le structure
vaccinales aussi on les connaît
des choses on a des choses à améliorer
très certainement mais justement ça sera
l'objet aussi de de cette mission il me
reste plus qu'à vous remercier beaucoup
pour la qualité de vos réponses et puis
vous pouvez apporter des réponses
écrites complémentaires
bien entendu qu'on vous a transmis et
puis nous allons lever la séance en vous
rappelant que nous nous retrouvons la
semaine prochaine
la semaine prochaine pour l'audition de
la NSM à 13h30
mercredi 15 oui
merci beaucoup